je vous parle très souvent de l'univers
merveilleux des smartphones parce que
des smartphones y en a tout le temps de
tous les côtés qui sortent dans le haut
de gamme le très haut de gamme le milieu
de gamme l'antre égalemnet partout il ya
des gammes de plus en plus complexes
mais il ya une marque dont je vous ai
pas beaucoup parler dans le segment
milieu entre et du milieu de gamme et
bien c'est au pot et j'ai eu tort parce
que au pot c'est une excellente marque
regarder autant dans ce qu'ils ont fait
que la gamme coop offline x3 lepreau le
néo le light les produits qui sont super
intéressant avec beaucoup d'innovations
dont copeaux est une marque qui innovent
on peut donc se demander qu'est ce qu'il
nous propose dans l'entrée du milieu de
gamme et des regardez regardez ça vous
ne rêvez pas ils sont là et sont souvent
vous ça c'est le au pot à 54 5 g il est
cool il est 5 g et puis surtout il fait
pas de jolies choses et ça c'est le au
pot à 94,5 j'ai regardé la boîte bouge
tellement il a de sortir donc ses
smartphones jeu les hawks et j'ai
regardé et testez donc aujourd'hui temps
vous dire ce que je pense et en plus de
ça on fait une petite parenthèse une
toute petite parenthèse parce que au pot
ne fait pas que des smartphones il faut
également l'audio d'ailleurs une peau à
dessus monde connecté j'en ai parlé il
ya quelques temps mais elle est toujours
d'actualité mais au-delà de ça ils font
aussi des écouteurs et là vous avez les
au pot encore free 2 99 euros avec une
réduction bruit active
oui vous ne rêvez pas donc on va
regarder tout ça on va surtout regarder
ça on va essayer voir quelle est la
différence au ras des cils sont
intéressants s'ils sont faits pour vous
quels usages qu'on va faire pour aller
au partir en vacances peut-être que
c'est pas moi en tout cas je vais pas
tarder à y aller
[Musique]
voilà les deux petites bêtes on va
retrouver ici le à 54 ans le 54e un peu
plus épais que le à 94 pas forcément
simple de s'en rendre compte comme ça
surtout au travers d'une vidéo mais je
puis vous assurer
on sent un peu plus d'épaisseur ici en
termes de poids on est à 190 g donc
c'est pas non plus la mer à boire est
tandis que à 94 est un peu plus léger
173 g et surtout beaucoup plus fin plus
facile à prendre en main après y'a rien
de déconnant ici mais c'est vrai quand
j'ai les deux comme ça et que je les
compare je préfère celui là je préfère
tout de suite le à 94 et ça me paraît
normal ou grosse différence sur le à 54
et bien j'ai mon capteur d'empreintes
digitales de côté ça déroule rapidement
tandis que de l'autre côté et bien il
est situé sous l'écran voyez je pose mon
doigt ça dès lors où tout aussi bien
après c'est une question de tarifs dans
les deux cas vous déverrouillez bien
vous avez un petit différence au niveau
de votre caméra de celle fille elle va
être un peu plus grande sur l'a54 est un
peu plus discrète sur le à 94 noeuds ça
me paraît normal on le dit tout de suite
ce produit-là lui à 54 tel qu'il est
présenté là il coûte 259 euros 90 il ya
des promos ne voit pas la fin de la
vidéo tandis que le à 94 et à 359 euros
90 avec des pros monde en parle
également à la fin de la vidéo point
connaître c'est la différence au niveau
des écrans alors sur lui à 54,13 le
monde très rapidement vous avez un écran
lcd saluer tps 6,5 pouces full hd + à
405 pp on passe très rapidement les les
specs vous avez ici un taux de
rafraîchissement de 90 heures ce qui va
porter un peu plus de fluidité lorsque
vous allez bien scrollé notamment joël
de jeu donc ça c'est plutôt pas mal
vous avez un taux d'échantillonnage
tactile qui va jusqu'à 180 hertz
donc ça c'est pas mal pour les
expériences de jeu alors attention ici
vous n'avez pas de smartphone avec le
plus de performance non en parlant
quelques attendons pour limiter pas
forcément un truc avec le plus dingue
dingue haut mais il faut être plus c'est
quand même plutôt pas mal tandis que de
l'autre côté
eh bien vous avez un écran amoled un
mollet et ça ça me plaît beaucoup plus
des couleurs qui seront plus sympas des
noirs profonds des contraste infini en
tout cas c'est comme ça qu'on va venir
définir un écran amoled
vous avez une diagonale de 6 43 pouces
full hd + à 409 pixels par pouce ici
vous n'avez pas de taux de
rafraîchissement de 90 hertz et vous
avez un taux d'échantillonnage tactile
qui va varier à 136,1 m
ce qui va être normal jusqu'à 180 m en
mode jeu et ses smartphones ils ont des
hauts parleurs forcément son venir
écouter de la musique c'est mieux
d'avoir des hauts parleurs alors les
haut parleurs il
ils sont beaux nos on n'a pas des haut
parleurs stéréo on s'en doutera dans
cette gamme de prix elle a des
haut-parleurs mono et pas stéréo
néanmoins la qualité correcte on n'a pas
réinventé la roue ici on n'a pas fait un
truc complètement dingue ou d'un gros
mais c'est correct par rapport à ce
qu'on retrouve sur le marché
autre point qui est sympa à regarder ces
planqués juste là et ces planqués juste
l'ajout de monde parce que les deux
longs et bien c'est la fameuse petite
prise jack
alors la prise jack on la retrouve très
très très souvent dans ce segment de
prix et c'est normal et en plus de ça
ici vous avez des bleus tout cinq points
sur les deux voilà comme ça vous êtes
tranquille vous êtes heureux vous avez
ça dockers tout ce qu'ils font il ya
plein de codecs aussi tous les côtés
donc du point de vue audio l'expérience
est correct convenant pas complètement
dingos mais qu'on va mais si vous voulez
aller plus loin c'est là qu'on fait la
parenthèse eh bien vous avez les amp aux
anc offrit deux heures les enfants
compris 2 les opposants cauffry 2 ils
sont sympas ils sont trés coup alors la
particularité qu'ils ont c'est qu'ils
gênent dans vos oreilles les oui sont
des écouteurs dont il ya côté très
pratique vous mettez vos vies c'est pas
que vous les avez regardés ce mec comme
ça à vous les prenez vous les posez
d'un côté et de l'autre alors ce qui est
très sympa c'est que vous avez si un
petit mode est activé vous appuyez up la
trance par annecy donc là j'ai mis le
mode transe pendant longtemps de ce qui
va autour de moi et si je rap hip noise
cancellation donc ça c'est très cool à
99 euros 99 quasiment 100 euros alors à
quasiment 100 euros qu'est ce qu'on a
chez au pot on a une qualité qu'il bonne
on a une qualité qui est honnête on a
une bonne qualité audio
on n'a pas les écouteurs avec le spectre
le plus large c'est pas là vont avoir un
grosse basse qui ronronne mais au moins
tout ce qu'on va retrouver ici et
cohérent le petit étui est sympa on peut
laisser très facilement dans une poche
et puis il faut être plus à 99.99 ça
vaut le coup alors je vous dis tout de
suite petite parenthèse deuxième une
parenthèse dans la parenthèse
ouvrez les crochets il coûte 99 cents 99
mais vous avez un code de pronos qui
s'affiche quelque part là il est
compliqué donc je voulais affiches et là
je vous le mets aussi dans la
description qui vous donne 30 euros de
réduction supplémentaire ce qui fait que
vous les avez à 69 euros 99 des
écouteurs de au pot avec une réduction
brute active parenthèse fermée
revenons à nos moutons nos deux
smartphones alors pour les repérer le
plus fin vous savez que c'est le à 94
celui là c'est lui à sa confiance à
celle de 94 ya une différence au niveau
de la performance au niveau des
processeurs au niveau du l'a54 vous avez
un snapdragon 480 5 g
et un processeur milieu de gamme ça peut
être le plus fou fou celui qui vous
enverra sur la lui dit qu'il fallait
tout les plus dingues
néanmoins pour venir vous amuser
naviguer à regarder des films des séries
car quelques petits jeux soyez pas trop
gourmand et bien il détiendra il a la
particularité d'être 5g donc ça c'est
bien donc bon on a de la polyvalence ici
on en plus si giga de ram 64 giga de
stockage de l'alpe et derrière catherine
bon là c'est standard ça marche bien
tandis que là on est chez mediatek mais
on a un truc un peu plus musclé
s'indigne city huit cents us oui s'il
vous plaît également 5 g alors il fera
un peu plus de choses que le 482
qualcomm comme un snapdragon 480 on va
l'appeler par son nom entier pour ne pas
le vexer
c'est une référence de médiathèque qui
est intéressante ludothèque développe
toujours ses gammes et se dit même city
lui sont utiles et plutôt cool est
plutôt intéressant donc pour revenir
faire à peu près les mêmes usages en
allant un peu plus loin au niveau du
gaming et bien vous aurez de quoi faire
et ça c'est cool et ça c'est agréable
ici vous avez 8 gigas de ram et 128 go
de stockage donc voyez vous avez un peu
plus de ram et un peu plus de stockage
sur le à 94 et vous avez un petit peu
moins de performance
un petit peu moins drame et un petit
point de stockage sur lui à 54 après la
question à se poser c'est vous vos
usages qu est ce que vous allez faire
est-ce que vous jouez beaucoup alors si
vous jouez beaucoup et bien vous allez
forcément sur le à 94 francs sachant
qu'ici vous n'êtes pas sur un flagship
vous n'êtes pas sûr indique trois procès
non plus combien lui demander dont vous
n'allez pas voir ici le meilleur de la
performance mais ça reste honnête ça
reste cohérent et c'est pas mal
voilà après c'est une question de budget
savoir à peu près pour vous ce qui va
fonctionner ce qui va passer ou pas
passé autrefois qui est super
intéressant c'est la question de
l'autonomie sur l'a54 vous avez meurtris
de cinq millions d'emplois tandis que
sur le celui ci le à 94 avait une
batterie de 4300 distille parquet parker
vous avez vu par contre la grosse
différence c'est que sur lui à 54 vous
avez de la recharge 10 watts et pas très
très rapide tout quand on sait que s'y
opposent savent aller très très vite et
là par contre ils ont mis de la vous 4.0
alors là vous 4.10 en tout cas ce
qu'elle fait bien l'argent 30 watts on
recherche donc trois fois plus vite
elle vous permet de recharger de 0 à 80
% seulement 39 minutes et une charge
complète en 58 minutes ce qui nous
intéresse également
eh bien c'est la question de l'autonomie
combien de temps vous allez les garder
le à 54 il très autonome jusqu'à deux
jours et demi ça c'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est dxomark donc bravo dxomark
dont c'est certifié s'est testé en labo
donc ça c'est cool
tandis que le à 94 aller jusqu'à deux
jours autant vous dire
déjà là deux jours de jours et mi
autonomie je pense que vous avez ce
qu'il faut le seul petit point de détail
sur le à 54 c'est de vous dire au moment
où j'ai besoin de leur chargement dont
j'aurai besoin de le recharger
il faut j'anticipe un peu parce qu'une
batterie de 5000 milliampères heures à
recharger en 10 watts ça prend un peu de
temps donc il faut avoir un petit moment
devant soi il ya un truc est super
intéressant sur celles de smartphones
c'est l'expérience logiciel vous êtes
sur collants os
11.1 basé sur un android 11 alors
colorés sont ce point j'en ai déjà parlé
j'ai fait une vidéo dessus vous invitent
à venir les regarder pour tout découvrir
c'est vraiment une superbe expérience
et ce qui est super également c'est la
personnalisation vous pouvez aller très
très loin au niveau des icônes des
animations même de l'animation pour le
capteur d'empreintes digitales enfin il
ya vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de choses
à faire
une fois de plus je vous renvoie la
vidéo sur color os 11.1 alors ce qui est
assez intéressant est que ces produits
c'est que vous avez la même
configuration au niveau des capteurs
photo vous avez dans les deux cas un
grand-angle de 40 8 mégapixels ouvre à f
1.7 vous avez un ultra grand-angle
absolument absolument 8 mégapixels
couvre f 2.2 avec un champ de vision 219
degrés vous avez de la macro 2
mégapixels couvre f 2.4 et vous avez un
capteur au mono de 2 mégapixels qui ont
également aidé 2.4 c'est la même chose
et vous avez une caméra de celle fille à
l'avant d'un côté comme de l'autre de 16
mégapixels la différence c'est que sur
le à 54 elle ouvre à f 2.0 tandis qu'ici
sur le à 94 elle ouvre à f 2.4 sinon il
n'y a pas grande grande différence pour
faire de la vidéo alors bon je vous le
dis c'est vraiment pour le savoir mais
parce que l' usage vidéo c'est pas
forcément ce qu'on va dire recherché ici
sur lui à 54 1080p à 30 images par
seconde ici quatre cas 30 images par
seconde je pense que la vidéo dans
parlons un peu plus tard chez oppose sur
la gamme raynaud qui devrait être je dis
bien devrait être renouvelée très
rapidement donc ça on en parlera et le
gros focus vidéo il sera là ici pour
faire de la vidéo mais je vous le montre
pas parce que pour moi il ya globalement
très très peu d'intérêt fait qu'est
super intéressant vous allez voir une
petite différence entre le à 54 et le à
94 au niveau du rendu des photos pour
qu'on les ait fait exactement au même
endroit au même moment alors ici je vous
montrerai pas de photos de nuit non plus
parce que c'est pas un smartphone qui
est optimisé pour la photo de nuit déjà
vous n'avez aucune stabilisation optique
et puis surtout son parti pour ça
regardez là on est sur le à 54,54
capteur principal bon ça fait somme
toute un petit peu le tas pour voir sur
les hautes lumières c'est un peu plus
délicat ici mais à rien
bien déconnant l'ultra grand temps que
fonctionne c'est un poil différent mais
ça fonctionne ok on va passer très très
très très rapidement là dessus voyez que
c'est très très cohérent lorsqu'on vient
de zoomer il ya tout de suite
ll go vient compenser c'est pas dingue
dingue mais c'est normal il à reggane
question en prenant ici pour autant
voyez là je me mets dans une zone
d'ombré
le ciel n'est pas cramé j'ai bien le
détail des feuilles je vois mon tronc
d'arbre ici de côté sa fonction sera
bref ça me paraît quand même plutôt pas
mal est assez cohérent pour voir que je
suis sur un smartphone qui coûte pas
forcément extrêmement cher même si ça
reste quand même beaucoup d'argent
l'ultra grand oncle sera un peu moins
précis bref un peu ce qu'on retrouve
classiquement sur beaucoup de
smartphones donc rien de bien surprenant
ici il ya un peu plus de mal je suis
dans une zone d'ombré avec les hautes
lumières au fond ici c'est plus dur pour
lui mais une fois de plus sur le
smartphone à 250 euros ça paraît
extrêmement normal on peut faire la
macro mais c'est une galère son nom
c'est pas beau je vous le déconseille on
oublie la macro la caméra de cette fille
et un petit peu terne mais malgré tout
ce si beau et fardée selphy pour revenir
quelques souvenirs ça marchera
le rendu est un petit peu mieux sur le à
94 alors c'est pas complètement magique
magic non plus ce qu'on va retrouver ici
au niveau des hautes lumières sur ses
feuilles là mais c'est un peu mieux
lorsqu'on vient nous mais on perd
toujours un peu en qualité mais c'est
quand même un petit peu mieux voyez par
exemple et simon si elle sera quand même
un peu plus bleue j'aurai plus de
détails ça sera plus sympa il ya une
meilleure gestion de l'expo et une
meilleure gestion globale pour voir
qu'on est sur des mêmes capteurs ça
fonctionne quand même pas mal ici
toujours le même problème au niveau de
l'expo lorsque vous avez beaucoup de
lumière au fond
les photos seront un peu meilleures sur
le à 94 que le à 54 mais une fois de
plus il ya 100 euros d'écart à vous de
voir s'il est possible ou pas dans tous
les cas la macro je dis non et j'aime
pas voilà je trouve ça sert à rien on
oublie complètement la macro on peut
bien faire quelques petites photos en
cette fille voilà si on veut c'est pas
des rivaux d'un go mais ça fonctionnera
de smartphones qui ont double 4 note
aussi mme 5g du nfc pour le paiement
dématérialisé et du wifi wifi wifi 5ème
pas de souci c'est qu'ils n'ont pas de
certification ip mais rien de bien
déconnant ici dans cette gamme de prix
deux produits qui sont assez
intéressants lors du tour de suisse
qu'il fasse au niveau du pic alors haut
niveau
oui on a une différence de 100 euros
entre les deux produits sur le à 54 ça
c'est la boîte du à 54 vous êtes à 259
euros 90 et roman il ya des promos sur
le site de hope au le lien est en bas
dans la description tandis que sont le à
94,6 la boîte du 94 est à 359 euros 90
on a donc 100 euros d'écart entre les
deux produits
et il ya aussi une promo sur le à 94 en
ce moment en tout cas donc aller faire
un petit tour à tour de la description
c'est super intéressant alors la
différence on va la retrouver un petit
peu au niveau de la photo parce que même
si on a la même configuration il ya une
toute petite différence elle est pas
énorme mais elle existe quand même la
différence a surtout est la performance
ça va être la qualité de l'écran si vous
aimez regarder des films des séries que
vous voulez une meilleure qualité et
bien forcément vous en douterez le plus
cher sera mieux pourquoi parce que vous
avez de l'aide et la molette c'est bien
et c'est beau les noirs sont vraiment
noir les contrats sont infinies enfin
bref ça marche bien c'est très très cool
après c'est toujours une question
d'argent donc bill vous bien que si vous
voulez un beau smartphone de au pot dans
les deux cas ils sont sympas les
finitions sont très belle avec deux
couleurs vous avez un espèce de violer
avec des différents reflet que j'aime
beaucoup que vous avez le confort ce
noir là le speg côté twilight est aussi
très sympa si vous voulez un joli
produit de au pot et que vous avez un
jazz autour de 250 euros par un petit
peu moins ça des pronoms n'oubliez pas
aller voir en bas ça c'est une propos
qui est intéressante et qui est tient
vraiment la route
si vous avez un peu plus d'argent et que
vous voulez un processeur un poil plus
rapide un écran d'une meilleure qualité
et bien vous avez celui là vous avez le
à 94,5 deuil dans les deux cas vous avez
un smartphone 5j alors pour profiter de
la saint-gilles bouffonne abonnement 5 g
sinon mais voilà ça glisse ça me
paraissait normal mais c'est promis je
trouve intéressant et je vous le dis
vous complétez tout ça avec ce produit
là que vous trouvez à 69 cents 99 cet
été une fois de plus tout est dans la
description et bah ça vaut le coup ça
vous fait un super package
donc si vous n'avez pas d'écouteurs aux
pauvres en cauffry 2 avec réduction
proactive à moins de 100 euros et ça
c'est cool
et puis si vous voulez aussi un beau
smartphone de au pot avec expérience
colorware parce que je vis je le redis
je signe je persiste ce qui fait souvent
la grosse différence au niveau des
produits qui sont somme toute assez
similaire au niveau des specs
et bien c'est l'expérience logiciel est
ici colorware 11
j'aime beaucoup ça marche très bien
c'est très cool donc ça c'est aussi un
très gros point fort pour repos
vous de me dire vous oui vous vous
derrière l'écran toi qui est derrière à
qu'est-ce que vous tu en penses pas ce
que vous en pensez
qu'est ce que vous pensez de l'opo
première chose qu'on peut vous aimez
bien c'est une marque qui vous parle que
vous parle pas est-ce que vous avez déjà
acheté des produits la gamme à devaux
est ce que ça vous botte ça vous arrive
vous avez un retour d'expérience dites
le moi en bas en commentaire et puis est
ce que vous avez acheté des produits de
au pot en audio il y en a pas mal y en a
plusieurs
mark et moi tout ça en bas en
commentaire sur ceux des gros bisous
beaucoup d'un mot condé souhaite vous
retrouve très très très très très vite
c'est l'été on y va un peu plus ou
mousse on y voit un peu plus light pour
attaquer la rentrée au taquet baby loup
d'amour a très vite ciao